Game of Thrones people are very excited
about it is this something you get
excited about I wanted to watch that
show and my wife is african-american and
she goes bill I don't care about white
people in the Middle Ages she just finds
some boring yeah so I never got to watch
it but I'm kind of glad that I didn't
because when I saw that little kid was
the king I saw a little Joffrey
yeah and he's going up cut his tongue
out and these people are listening to
him I just I hate spoiled brats you know
what I mean in the supermarket I
literally want to like kick him I don't
want to tip him over when I see him
actin like that so I just think it would
you know I started going to like you
believe it or not I started going to
therapy for my anger issues this is you
post therapy I'm only 2 n I'm only 2 & 2
in okay ya know the elevator only goes
to floor for now you should go all the
way up to the penthouse yeah yeah you're
okay okay would you I want you to screen
this episode for your therapist okay
yeah I'm sure she'd have a lot to say
about it but I mean I'm trying I'm
trying yeah I got no I got a wife and
kid now so it's just like I don't want
to like I was comparing a lot of my
behavior to what I saw growing up yep so
I was being like well I'm not doing that
but I don't realize that other people
didn't grow up around that stuff so I
was freaking people out I don't like
yell at people as much as I yell about
stuff so right I'm just trying not to do
that you're revolving you're trying to
evolve but then also if I don't yell
about anything everything else I'm doing
really well at so selfishly it's like if
I fix this like what can she get mad at
and then I got her you just did this
whole thing about how you're revolving
as a husband and then it resolved what
you saying and if I do that then I got
it yeah it's all the revenge you haven't
noticed that in your relationship like
I've noticed being married and we're
always working on me like like my wife
is some completed work you know it's
just like what when's the the light
goodness you know shine on you uh-huh
this crowd has hated me for three days
that's not true